Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Hello, happy Easter. In the first half of the first century AD, there took place probably the single best-known event in all human history. There are four main accounts, all written decades afterwards, and this is one of them. Then the soldiers of the governor took Jesus into the praetorium,
感谢您收听《历史其余》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告收听、抢先收听系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。大家好，复活节快乐。公元一世纪的上半叶，人类历史上最广为人知的事件可能就发生在那个时期。主要有四份记载，全都是在几十年后写成的，而这就是其中之一。随后，总督的士兵把耶稣带进了总督府，
and they gathered the whole battalion before him, and they stripped him and put a scarlet robe upon him, and plaiting a crown of thorns, they put it on his head and put a reed in his right hand. And kneeling before him, they mocked him, saying, Hail, King of the Jews! And they spat upon him and took the reed and struck him on the head. And when they'd mocked him, they stripped him of the robe and put his own clothes on him and led him away to crucify him. As they went out, they came upon a man of Cyrene, Simon by name. This man they compelled to carry his cross. And when they came to a place called Golgotha, the place of the skull, they offered him wine to drink mingled with gall. But when he tasted it, he would not drink it. And when they had crucified him, they divided his garments among them by casting lots.
他们叫齐了整营的兵，围着他，剥去他的衣服，给他穿上一件朱红色的袍子，又用荆棘编成冠冕戴在他头上，拿一根芦苇放在他右手里。他们跪在他面前，戏弄他说：“恭喜，犹太人的王啊！”又向他吐口水，拿芦苇敲他的头。戏弄完了，就脱下他的袍子，给他穿上他自己的衣服，带他出去钉十字架。他们出来的时候，遇见一个古利奈人，名叫西门。他们强迫这个人背他的十字架。到了一个地方名叫各各他，就是骷髅地，他们拿调着苦胆的酒给他喝。他尝了尝，就不肯喝。他们把他钉在十字架上后，就抽签分了他的衣服。
Then they sat down and kept watch over him there. And over his head, they put the charge against him, which read, This is Jesus, the King of the Jews. So Tom Holland, that's a story with which we and a large proportion, probably almost all of our listeners, are extremely familiar. And there are all kinds of conversations we could have about the historicity of this, about whether Jesus really existed, about whether this really happened. But what we wanted to focus on today was the act of crucifixion itself. Because obviously, when we think of the crucifixion, we think of Jesus. But presumably at the time, Tom, I mean, you'll know far more about this than me, crucifying somebody would not have been unusual, would it, in the Roman world?
然后他们坐在那里看守他。在他的头上方，写着控告他的罪状：“这是犹太人的王耶稣。”那么，汤姆·霍兰，这个故事我们以及很大一部分——可能几乎全部——听众都极为熟悉。关于这件事的历史真实性，关于耶稣是否真的存在过，关于这是否真的发生过，我们可以展开各种各样的讨论。但我们今天想关注的是钉十字架这一行为本身。因为显然，当我们想到钉十字架时，我们就会想到耶稣。但在当时，汤姆，我的意思是，你对这方面的了解远比我多，在罗马世界里，把某人钉死在十字架上应该并不罕见吧？
No, crucifixion was a very common form of execution. And it was a form of execution that was, it was basically seen as the absolute worst that you could inflict. So as a governor of a province, if you were faced with rebellion, banditry, insurrection, you could inflict a range of punishments. So you could burn someone to death. You could put them to the beasts. So make them a public show in the arena and people would cheer as they watched them devoured by wild animals. Or you could crucify them. And crucifixion was seen as the worst of these fates because it was protracted and humiliating. Even more humiliating than being burnt to death or devoured by lions. And it was that idea of being made a public spectacle that I think reflects the way in which, for the Romans,
是的，钉十字架是一种非常普遍的行刑方式。这是一种基本上被视为你能施加的最极端惩罚的行刑方式。因此，作为一省总督，如果你面临叛乱、盗匪活动或暴动，你可以施加多种惩罚。你可以把人活活烧死。你可以把他们喂猛兽。也就是让他们在竞技场里公开出丑，当他们被野兽吞食时，人们会欢呼喝彩。或者你可以把他们钉死在十字架上。钉十字架被认为是最悲惨的结局，因为这个过程漫长且极具羞辱性。甚至比被活活烧死或被狮子吞食还要屈辱。正是这种成为公开展示品的想法，我认为它反映了对罗马人来说，
to be shamed was almost as terrible as to be tortured. And that's why, as well as being the paradigmatic fate that was visited on rebels, it was also the paradigmatic fate that was visited on slaves. So when Jesus, I mean, we'll come back to Jesus' crucifixion, but he's been crucified as a sign of humiliation, as a sign that he is no more than a slave. And that's why the King of the Jews stuff is so, it's bitterly ironic, I suppose.
遭受羞辱几乎和遭受酷刑一样可怕。正因如此，它不仅是加诸叛乱者的典型结局，也是加诸奴隶的典型结局。所以当耶稣——我的意思是，我们等会儿会回到耶稣被钉十字架这件事上——但他被钉十字架作为一种羞辱的标志，表明他不过是一个奴隶。这就是为什么那些关于“犹太人的王”的说法如此……我猜这带有极其辛辣的讽刺意味。
Absolutely. So it was, crucifixion is called supplicium servile by a Roman writer called Valerius Maximus, the punishment of slaves. Josephus, the Jewish writer who records the war that destroys Jerusalem, he calls it the most wretched of deaths. Even a grammarian called Varro, he writes about the crux, the cross, and he says that the word of it is harsh on the ears. So everything about it is cruel, savage, bitter.
绝对是的。所以它被一个叫瓦莱里乌斯·马克西姆斯的罗马作家称为“奴隶的刑罚”（supplicium servile）。犹太作家约瑟夫斯记录了毁灭耶路撒冷的战争，他称之为最悲惨的死法。甚至连一个名叫瓦罗的语法学家在谈到“十字架”（crux）时，也说这个词听起来刺耳。所以关于它的一切都是残酷的、野蛮的、痛苦的。
And that generates a kind of paradox, which is that, although, as you say, it's incredibly common, and it's something that serves the Roman world as an emblem of Rome's power. It's a statement about Rome's authority, about its right to inflict brutal torture on those who oppose them. It's also something that the Romans themselves seem to have been a bit embarrassed about. They didn't like to draw attention to it. Crucifixions don't happen in the center of town. So in the account you read, Golgotha, which is otherwise unattested, is a place presumably outside the city limits. And in Rome itself, crucifixions took place on a remote area of the Esquiline Hill that only very gradually, as Rome expands, gets kind of developed. But for a long time, it has this kind of taint. And that carrion taint, which hangs over crucifixion,
这就产生了一种悖论：尽管如你所说，这极其普遍，并且它在罗马世界中充当了罗马权力的象征——它是关于罗马权威的声明，宣称罗马有权对那些反对他们的人施以残酷的酷刑——但它也是罗马人自己似乎有点感到尴尬的事情。他们不喜欢引起人们对它的注意。钉十字架不会发生在市中心。所以在你读到的记载中，各各他在其他地方没有记载，它大概是一个在城市边界之外的地方。在罗马城本身，钉十字架发生在埃斯奎利尼山一个偏远的地区，随着罗马的发展，该地区只是非常逐渐地被开发。但在很长一段时间里，它都带有这种污点。而这种挥之不去、如同腐肉般的污点，
means that the Romans themselves are actually very reluctant to acknowledge that it's a Roman practice. So they say, yes, we do it, but this is a practice that has its origins among barbarians. So it's- Oh, that's interesting. Yeah. Yeah. So let's get back to the root of it. So when, Tom, do we get our first references to crucifixions? It predates the empire, presumably. It does. It's complicated, though, because we think of crucifixion as a kind of set practice, that there are set rules and so on. It's hard to know whether that's the case. The only accounts we have of an actual crucifixion by the Romans are the four gospel accounts, which in itself is
意味着罗马人自己其实非常不愿意承认这是一种罗马的做法。所以他们会说，是的，我们这么做，但这是一种起源于野蛮人的做法。所以它是——哦，这很有意思。是的。是的。那么让我们回到它的根源。汤姆，我们最早是在什么时候看到关于钉十字架的记载的？它大概早于帝国时期吧。确实如此。不过情况很复杂，因为我们认为钉十字架是一种成文的做法，有固定的规则等等。很难知道事实是否真的如此。我们拥有的关于罗马人实际执行钉十字架的唯一记录就是四部福音书的记载，这本身就
telling, I think. The Romans are reluctant to go into all the gory details. And if we go back before the Romans, there are various accounts, chiefly by Greek writers, of penalties that seem to involve suspending someone, hanging them, putting them up in a public place and suspending them from a tree or a piece of wood. And so this fate could be crucifixion as we understand it in the sense that Christians would understand it today, but it could also be impalement or something like that. So I have a question, Tom friend of the show alexander the great is said to have crucified large numbers of people after capturing the city of tyre yeah he was crossed they wouldn't let him in to worship a statue of heracles yeah uh so that now is that
很能说明问题，我认为。罗马人不愿意陷入所有血淋淋的细节中。如果我们追溯到罗马人之前，会有各种各样的记载，主要是希腊作家的记载，关于似乎涉及将人悬挂起来、吊起来、把他们放在公共场所并从树上或一块木头上悬挂下来的惩罚。因此，这种结局可能是我们今天基督徒所理解的那种钉十字架，但它也可能是穿刺刑或类似的东西。所以我有这样一个问题，汤姆，节目的好朋友亚历山大大帝据说在攻占泰尔城后把大量的人钉死在十字架上，是的，他被交叉了，他们不让他进去崇拜赫拉克勒斯的神像，是的，呃，那么现在这是
project because of course the accounts of alexander that we have are written later so is that projecting is that putting back a sort of Roman practice and thinking that he must have done it? Or is it plausible that Alexander was crucifying people and that that was a common practice in the, what is that, the fourth century BC? I think it's likelier to be an actual reflection of what he did because Alexander is invading the Persian Empire and he is taking on the role of a Persian king. And crucifixion or at least suspending people, impaling people, hanging them in public so that they suffer and die in public
投射吗？因为当然，我们拥有的关于亚历山大的记载是后来写的，所以这是一种投射吗？是把一种罗马式的做法强加回去，并认为他当时一定这么做了吗？或者说，亚历山大当时确实在把人钉死在十字架上，这在——那是什么时候，公元前四世纪？——是一种常见的做法，这种可能性合理吗？我认为这更像是对他所做事情的真实反映，因为亚历山大正在入侵波斯帝国，他正在承担波斯国王的角色。钉十字架，或者至少是把人悬挂起来、穿刺、公开吊起来，让他们在公众面前遭受痛苦并死去，
is seen as something that originates with the Persians. So Ali Ansari, who's been a guest on the show many times, and says everything began with the Persians, will be delighted to hear the crucifixion. Top tortures are among them. Well, the Persians are famous for the sophistication and subtlety of their torture. And much, much later, the Marquis
被认为起源于波斯人。所以阿里·安萨里（曾多次作为嘉宾上节目，并说一切都始于波斯人）听到钉十字架是顶级酷刑之一，一定会很高兴。嗯，波斯人以其酷刑的复杂性和微妙性而闻名。而且在很久很久以后，萨德侯爵，
de Sade, who is a guy who really knows what he's talking about when it comes to torture, says that the Persians of all the peoples who have ever lived were the greatest at torturing people to death. And the idea that you punish rebels by exposing them to humiliation, the humiliating gaze, is something that certainly goes back to Darius the Great, who is ruling. So he's the king who sends the expedition that gets defeated at the Battle of Marathon,
一个在酷刑方面真正内行的人，说在所有曾经生活过的人中，波斯人最擅长将人折磨至死。通过将叛乱者暴露在羞辱中、暴露在羞辱的目光下来惩罚他们的想法，当然可以追溯到正在统治的大流士大帝。所以他就是那个派出的远征军在马拉松战役中被击败的国王，
the expedition to destroy Athens. And he comes to power amid a coup and all kinds of Persians, provinces, cities rebel against him. And among them is Babylon. And Darius takes 3,000 Babylonians and he crucifies them, which could, as I say, mean he impales them. But certainly this is remembered. This is a kind of kingly thing to do. This is what the great king does. So I imagine that you know that there is an echo of that behavior yeah so so a slightly pedantic question you said uh he crucifies them which may mean that he impales them so that implies to me that the word the original word that is being used is not the word
那支旨在消灭雅典的远征军。他在一场政变中上台，各种各样的波斯人、省份和城市都背叛了他。巴比伦就是其中之一。大流士抓了三千名巴比伦人并将他们钉死在十字架上，正如我所说，这可能意味着他把他们穿刺了。但无论如何，人们都记住了这一点。这是一种很像国王的行为。这就是伟大的国王所做的事。所以我猜你知道那种行为是有回响的，是的。所以——一个有点吹毛求疵的问题，你刚才说“他把他们钉死在十字架上，这可能意味着他把他们穿刺了”，这对我暗示，所使用的原始词汇并不是“钉十字架”这个词，
crucify right that it's some other translation or some other words that could mean crucifixion but could mean something else is that right there's some sort of vague into intermediate term well a stauros a stavros that's where the the greek name comes from the word stavros exactly uh is a is a a cross it's conventionally translated as a cross, but it could be a pole. It could be. It's hard because crucifixion becomes so famous and because the role it plays in Christianity is so key, it kind of, you know, we tend to back project
对吧？它是某种其他的翻译或其他可能意味着钉十字架但也可能意味着其他什么的词，是这样吗？有一种某种模糊的中间术语。嗯，“stauros”，希腊语名字就是从这个词来的，“stavros”，完全正确，呃，是一个——一个十字架，它通常被翻译成十字架，但它也可以是一根柱子。它可以是。这很难说，因为钉十字架变得如此著名，而且它在基督教中所起的作用又是如此关键，它在某种程度上，你知道，我们倾向于把
what happens there onto the early use of it by Greek writers. We can't know for sure. It could, you know, it could be a kind of range of things. But the key thing is that you are exposed to public obloquy. And that is absolutely the fundamental aspect of it. And it's what makes the crucifixion with a capital C so extraordinary and strange that this should be the foundational
那里发生的事情回溯投射到希腊作家早期对它的使用上。我们无法确切知道。它可能，你知道，是各种各样的事情。但关键是你要暴露在公众的唾弃之下。这绝对是最根本的方面。正是这一点使得大写字母的“十字架”和钉十字架变得如此非凡和奇妙，这应该成为基础性的
image. Because obviously for Christians, the key to Easter is the resurrection. It's the rising from the dead. That's the whole essence of the story. But that in terms of antiquity is not so unusual. Lots of mortals are raised up to the heavens um you know in the lifetime of jesus augusta caesar has been raised up to the heavens augusta caesar's um adoptive father julius caesar has been raised to the heavens there are all kinds of gods who who die and then get raised from the dead yeah obviously ancient egyptian religion is full of this isn't it yes yeah is this what happens to osiris or horus or somebody yeah so osiris gets killed loses his penis which is
意象。因为显然对于基督徒来说，复活节的关键是复活。是从死里复活。那是整个故事的精髓。但在古代，这并不是那么不寻常。许多凡人都被提升到了天堂，呃，你知道，在耶稣的有生之年，奥古斯都·凯撒就被提升到了天堂，奥古斯都·凯撒的呃养父尤利乌斯·凯撒也被提升到了天堂，有各种各样的神，他们死去然后从死里复活，是的，显然古埃及宗教到处都是这种内容，不是吗？是的，是的，这就是发生在奥西里斯、荷鲁斯或其他什么人身上的事吗？是的，所以奥西里斯被杀，失去了他的阴茎，这
obviously something that doesn't happen to jesus um and yes and then and then he gets resurrected to rule as the king of the dead yeah yeah so this is so this is all very common um but it's the humiliation that is unusual that That is the strangeness. That is the weirdness. And until you properly understand its significance in the Roman imagination and in the Greek imagination and indeed in the Jewish imagination, you don't properly understand how strange the whole thing is. Okay, well, let's talk a little bit about the Romans and crucifixion.
显然是耶稣身上没有发生的事，是的，然后——然后他复活了，作为死者的王统治，是的，是的。所以这一切都非常普遍，但不同寻常的是羞辱，那是陌生之处。那是诡异之处。除非你真正理解它在罗马人想象中、在希腊人想象中以及在犹太人想象中的意义，否则你就无法真正理解整件事是多么诡异。好吧，让我们多聊聊罗马人和钉十字架。
So do we have any sense, Tom, of the kind of people and the kind of crimes for which you would be crucified? Yeah, so as I said, it's chiefly visited on rebels against Roman rule in the provinces and on slaves. And it comes to serve as, therefore, a kind of warning to anyone, be they a slave rebelling against the master or a provincial rebelling against the power of Caesar, of what your fate will be. And one of the weirdest expressions of this is in the writings of Pliny, the elder. You love a bit of Pliny.
那么，汤姆，我们是否知道会被钉十字架的人群以及会招致这种刑罚的罪行有哪些？是的，正如我所说，它主要加诸省份中反抗罗马统治的叛乱者以及奴隶身上。因此，它成为了一种警告，无论是反抗主人的奴隶，还是反抗凯撒权力的省民，都在警告任何人你们的结局会是怎样。而这最奇怪的表现之一就见于老普林尼的著作中。你挺喜欢普林尼的。
I love a bit of Pliny. I love a bit of Pliny. I've been, for the new book I'm doing, I've been reading through all his natural history, which is this incredible kind of compendium of all kinds of, sometimes very, very accurate facts and sometimes not entirely accurate. And he covers, you know, natural phenomena and... It's like this podcast, Tom. Well, no, you're very against natural phenomena, aren't you? So he loves his birds, for instance, which you're very hostile to. We were already talking before recording this about whether we should do a podcast on the history of birds.
我很喜欢普林尼。我非常喜欢普林尼。为了我正在写的新书，我一直在阅读他所有的《自然史》，这是一部令人难以置信的宏编巨著，里面包含了各种各样、有时非常非常准确有时又并非完全准确的事实。他涵盖了，你知道，自然现象和……这就像这个播客一样，汤姆。好吧，不，你非常反对自然现象，不是吗？所以他很喜欢鸟类，比如说，而你对鸟类非常敌视。我们在录音前就已经讨论过我们是否应该做一个关于鸟类历史的播客。
Well, we're doing one with pigeons, of course. I reacted with incredulity. But all the fans will be horrified to hear this. But among them, he talks about animals and he talks about the lion as the king of the lions. And he has this extraordinary story about how Polybius, who is a Greek who accompanied Scipio Aemilianus, who destroyed Carthage in 146 BC, that he was with Scipio in Africa. And he saw Scipio crucify lions
好吧，我们当然会做一个关于鸽子的播客。我对此表示难以置信。但所有的粉丝听到这个都会感到惊恐。不过在其中，他谈到了动物，他把狮子称为狮子之王。他有一个非常不寻常的故事，讲述了波利比乌斯（他是一个希腊人，陪同在公元前146年毁灭迦太基的小西庇阿左右）如何在非洲与小西庇阿在一起。他看到小西庇阿将狮子钉死在十字架上，
so that the other lions, Pliny writes, would be deterred from attacking the cities of Africa by fear of suffering the same fate. That seems absolutely horrible and bizarre. Isn't it? Isn't it? I mean, is it plausible that he did that? Well, it's in Pliny. And also, Tom, would it act as a deterrent to other lions? I think it's unlikely.
这样一来，普林尼写道，其他的狮子就会因为害怕遭受同样的命运而不敢攻击非洲的城市。这听起来绝对可怕而诡异。不是吗？不是吗？我的他是真的做了那种事，这合理吗？好吧，它记载在普林尼的书里。而且，汤姆，这真的能起到震慑其他狮子的作用吗？我认为不太可能。
But obviously what it would do would act as a deterrent to people in Africa. I'm more shocked by that than I am by the crucifixion of thousands of people that we've talked about earlier in the podcast. Well, there's another crucifixion of animals story, which is the famous account of the Gauls who capture Rome, seize Rome. And they occupy the city. But the capital holds out and the Gauls are creeping up the side of the rock to try and storm the top. And the watchdogs don't bark.
但显然它对非洲的人类能起到震慑作用。我对这件事的震惊程度甚至超过了我们之前在播客中讨论过的数千人被钉死在十字架上的事。好吧，还有一个关于动物被钉十字架的故事，那是关于高卢人攻占罗马、占领罗马的著名记载。他们占领了城市。但卡皮托利姆山（Capitolium）坚守了下来，高卢人正顺着岩石侧面往上爬，企图冲上山顶。看门狗没有叫，
But the sacred geese of Juno, the the queen of the gods hiss and alert the guards and so um every year that on the anniversary of that day um the geese are put in a a litter and carried in triumph through the city but the watchdogs are crucified i mean it's it's through those like subsequent generations of dogs I mean that makes Jeremy Thorpe look positively we haven't had dogs being killed for a while so we're as it were resurrecting the
但朱诺（众神之后）的神圣鹅却发出嘶嘶声，惊醒了警卫，所以，呃，每年在那一天的周年纪念日，鹅都会被放在轿子里，在城中凯旋游行，但看门狗却被钉死在十字架上。我的意思是，通过这种后代犬只的遭遇——我的意思是，这让杰里米·索普（Jeremy Thorpe）看起来都显得相当温和了。我们已经有一段时间没有看到狗被杀了，所以我们可以说是正在复活这个传统。
tradition now the reason I asked about who was crucified and why was because when you answered that, both of the examples you gave were about rebels. So you're not crucified by and large for common or garden crime, even a murder.
现在，我之所以问关于谁被钉十字架以及为什么被钉十字架，是因为当你回答时，你举出的两个例子都是关于叛乱者的。所以你通常不会因为普通或一般的犯罪——甚至是一起谋杀——而被钉十字架。
It's rebellion against, it's a crime against the state, against the threat to the integrity of the state, is it, that is punishable by the order? And the natural order. Right. So you do, if you're a slave and you kill your master, then not only are you crucified, but everyone in the household is crucified.
这是对叛乱的惩罚，是对国家、对威胁国家完整性的罪行的惩罚，是秩序所惩罚的吗？以及自然秩序。对的。所以如果你是一个奴隶，你杀死了你的主人，那么不仅你会被钉十字架，家里所有人都会被钉十字架。
That, again, is ridiculously harsh. Well, so this happens, I think, I'm trying to remember, Tassadus writes about it, I think it's in the reign of Nero, that a senator is murdered by one of his slaves and there's something like kind of five he has 500 600 slaves something like that with women and children and actually even the romans are appalled at the prospect of you know all these slaves who are entirely innocent being killed and there is a kind of um there's a kind of brief campaign to say well do we really
这又是一个极其严厉的惩罚。好吧，所以这确实发生过，我想，我努力回忆一下，塔西陀对此有过记载，我想要么是在尼禄统治时期，一个参议员被他的一个奴隶杀害了，然后大约有那种——他有500、600个奴隶，诸如此类，包括妇女和儿童。事实上，甚至连罗马人都对这种前景感到震惊，你知道，所有这些完全无辜的奴隶都要被杀害，并且有一种呃——有一种短暂的呼吁运动说，好吧，我们真的
need to do this but they decide yeah we do so the whole lot the whole lot get crucified wow that is that is i was about to say that's tough love but there's no love in it no there's no love in that at all it's just no it's just tough um what about um obviously the most famous uh crucified slave uh certainly in the western in the in the modern Western imagination, is Spartacus. Was Spartacus crucified? Well, he's supposed to have been killed in the final battle. Obviously, if you go along with the Kirk Douglas film, then he isn't because everyone turns out to be Spartacus. And so they all get crucified. But the point of that, of course, is that the who are seen by Greeks as well as by Romans to be fitted for servitude.
需要这么做吗？但他们决定，是的，我们必须这么做。所以全部——全都被钉死在十字架上了。哇，那是——那是——我本来想说那是严厉的爱，但其中根本没有爱。不，这里面绝对没有爱，只有残酷。呃，那么——显然最著名的呃被钉十字架的奴隶，当然是在西方——在现代西方人的想象中——就是斯巴达克。斯巴达克被钉死在十字架上吗？好吧，他本该在最后的战斗中阵亡。显然，如果你顺着柯克·道格拉斯的电影来看，他就没有死，因为最后所有人都成了斯巴达克。所以他们全都被钉死了。但当然，这其中的重点是，被希腊人和罗马人视为适合做奴隶的人。
And therefore, Greeks and Romans tend not to worry about that particularly. But also among the people enslaved are Greeks who do not see themselves as a fit people to be enslaved. And so they are brought to Italy and to Sicily. And it's not like they are objecting to slavery as an institution. They're objecting to the fact that they are the slaves. That's the problem. And so through the second and first centuries BC, you have large numbers of slave insurrections.
因此，希腊人和罗马人往往不会特别担心这一点。但同样，在被奴役的人中也有希腊人，他们不认为自己是适合被奴役的人。所以他们被带到了意大利和西西里。这并不是说他们在反对奴隶制这种制度。他们反对的是他们自己成了奴隶。这才是问题所在。因此，在公元前二世纪和一世纪，你看到了大量的奴隶起义。
And they get dealt with incredibly brutally because maybe a quarter, maybe a third of the population of Italy by this point are slaves. So the Romans are sitting on the edge of a volcano. So this is very analogous to the situation in 19th century American South. Yes. Where you've got a large slave population, people live in a constant state of they're either brutalized and terrorized on the one hand, or they're the owners who live in fear constant state of, they're either brutalized and terrorized on the
他们遭到极其残酷的镇压，因为到这个时候，意大利四分之一甚至三分之一的人口可能都是奴隶。所以罗马人正坐在火山边缘。这与19世纪美国南方的局势非常相似。是的。在那里，你拥有庞大的奴隶人口，人们生活在一种持续的状态中：一方面他们遭受残酷对待和恐怖统治，或者他们是生活在恐惧中的主人。一方面他们遭受残酷对待和恐怖统治，或者他们是生活在恐惧中的主人，害怕起义。是的。因此被迫走极端。是的。
one hand, or they're the owners who live in fear of insurrection. Yes. And are therefore driven to extremes. Yes. And so therefore, it becomes incredibly important that every slave absolutely understand what will happen if they in any way, try and fight back. And so when Spartacus's rebellion is finished, famously, those who survive are crucified along the entire length of the Appian Way, which is across Italy to the heel of Italy. And these are serving as kind of billboards advertising Rome's power. That's what they're there for. And it's meant to be a kind of disgusting spectacle. Yeah, which it must have been. I mean, so let's talk a tiny bit about the mechanics of crucifixion.
所以，让每一个奴隶绝对明白如果他们以任何方式胆敢反抗将会发生什么，就变得极其重要。因此，当斯巴达克的起义被平定后，传说中，那些幸存者沿着整条阿庇亚古道被钉死在十字架上，这条路穿过意大利一直延伸到意大利的脚跟。而这些尸体就像是宣传罗马权力的巨幅广告牌。这就是它们在那里的目的。这本该是一种令人作呕的奇观。是的，它一定是的。我的意思是，让我们稍微谈谈钉十字架的技术细节。
Do we know much about that or our soul accounts? You said earlier on, if I heard you correctly, that our soul accounts really are the gospel accounts. So when historians write about crucifixion now, are they actually basing it on the Bible? It's very, very difficult to escape it. There is physical evidence for it so the earliest physical evidence was found uh in 1968 and it was in a tomb outside jerusalem wasn't jesus for anyone who wonders about that um it was someone a bit later um and what that shows is so it's the heel bone and there's a nail driven through it and it's still attached to the wood.
我们对此了解多少，还是说我们的唯一记录就是？你刚才说过，如果我没听错的话，我们唯一的记录真的就是福音书的记录。所以当历史学家现在撰写关于钉十字架的文章时，他们实际上是以《圣经》为基础的吗？要避开它是非常非常困难的。确实有这方面的物理证据，所以最早的物理证据是在1968年发现的，它在耶路撒冷城外的一座古墓里，那可不是耶稣的墓——对于任何好奇的人来说——那是稍后某个人的墓。
And what that shows is, so if you imagine, you know, how the crucifixion is portrayed in Christian art, the feet are crossed and a nail is kind of driven through the feet or maybe through the ankles. Through both your ankles at once yeah but but what this shows is that your your the side of the cross um the the feet are put on either side of the cross and then they're driven through the through the ankle again i mean and that of course would enhance the humiliation of the experience because you wouldn't be wearing a loincloth so your legs would be spread you'd be naked yeah you'd be naked and um and corroboration for that was actually found just before christmas in britain so yes you sent me the story the story in the story yeah you sent it from the guardian because i know you're a massive admirer of the guardian
而这表明的是——所以如果你想象一下，你知道，钉十字架在基督教艺术中是如何被描绘的，双脚交叉，一颗钉子穿过双脚或者可能是穿过脚踝。穿过你的双脚踝，是的，但这个证据表明，你的——十字架的侧面——双脚是放在十字架的两侧，然后钉子从脚踝处钉过去。再次说明，这当然会增加这段经历的羞辱感，因为你不会穿遮羞布，所以你的双腿会张开，你会赤身裸体。是的，你会赤身裸体，而且，圣诞节前不久在英国实际上发现了支持这一点的佐证，所以，是的，你发给我了那个故事——那个故事，在那个故事里，是的，你从《卫报》发给我的，因为我知道你是《卫报》的超级粉丝。
and they found so tell us about what they found yes so. So a whole kind of cemetery was excavated and the bones were removed. And then it was only, I think, you know, last year that they washed the mud off and they discovered the same thing had happened, that there was a nail embedded through the ankle. And this was clearly this unfortunate had suffered crucifixion. However, I mean, again, there's no firm or fast rule on this because it's perfectly possible that people were suspended by ropes. account well he he says that part of the um the fun of it for the executioners is to kind of spice it up to to vary it so he says that um you know one victim may be suspended upside down with his head facing the ground um others you know in the classical sense you know the the image of jesus with the arms spread along a yoke. Others, he says, I mean, horribly. And so this is where the confusion between crucifixion and
他们发现——所以告诉我们他们发现了什么。是的。所以挖掘出了一个完整的墓地，骨骼被移除了。然后直到，我想，你知道，去年他们洗掉泥土时，他们才发现同样的事情发生了，有一颗钉子嵌入了脚踝。这显然表明这个不幸的人遭受过钉十字架。然而，我的意思是，同样，对此并没有硬性规定，因为完全有可能人们是用绳子悬挂起来的。记载——好吧，他说，行刑者的“乐趣”之一就是给它加点料、使其多样化，所以他说，你知道，
impalement comes in, that people might drive a stake up through the genitals. So it's, and the variation of this seems to be important. So there's an account that Josephus writes about as the Romans are besieging Jerusalem, and they're trying to intimidate the defenders. And all the deserters, all the people who are kind of trying to slip out, who are armed, who are captured, they're crucified in front of the walls of the defenders to try and intimidate them. And Josephus describes how the soldiers, out of their hostility to the defending Jews, out of their hatred to them, that they kind of mix and match, that they will twist their victims into kind of strange positions, basically that it's a bit of a laugh. And so in the account from the gospel that you read, where they mock Jesus, that seems entirely
一个受害者可能会被倒挂着，头部面向地面，其他人，你知道，在经典意义上，你知道，耶稣双臂张开沿着横木的形象。其他人，他说，我的意思是，极其可怕。所以这就是钉十字架和穿刺刑之间的混淆产生的地方，人们可能会把一根桩子从生殖器刺进去。所以，这种变体似乎很重要。因此，有一个约瑟夫斯记载的故事，当时罗马人正在围攻耶路撒冷，他们试图恐吓守军。所有逃兵、所有试图溜出去但携带着武器却被俘虏的人，都被钉在守军城墙前以试图恐吓他们。约瑟夫斯描述了士兵们如何出于对防守的犹太人的敌意、出于对他们的仇恨，而进行混合搭配，他们把受害者扭曲成各种奇怪的姿势，基本上就是觉得这挺好笑的。所以在你读到的福音书的记载中，他们戏弄耶稣，
true to the evidence that we have for how the military, the security apparatus dealt with their victims. That in a sense, making the victim look ridiculous and grotesque and foolish was a crucial part of the punishment. The more amusing you could make it, the kind of more credit you get with your colleagues. Now, Tom, you haven't really answered my question about, in fact, you've utterly failed to answer the question. What was the question? The question was about how crucifixions worked in practice so what do we actually know are you are you yeah do you carry so let's in that biblical account a man carries a cross um there's a big crowd presumably there's all the stuff with later on with sponges there's a whole sort of yeah there's a whole load of goings on what do we
这似乎完全符合我们掌握的关于军队和安全机构如何对待受害者的证据。在某种程度上，让受害者看起来荒谬、怪诞和愚蠢是惩罚至关重要的一部分。你能把它搞得越滑稽，你在同事那里获得的“功劳”就越多。现在，汤姆，你并没有真正回答我的问题，事实上，你彻底没有回答这个问题。什么问题？问题是关于钉十字架在实际中是如何运作的，所以我们到底知道什么？你——你带着——那么在那段圣经记载中，一个人背着十字架，有一大群人，后来大概还有海绵之类的东西，整个过程有各种各样的事情发生，对于一次钉十字架——一次普通的钉十字架是什么样的，我们到底了解多少？
actually know about what a crucifixion an ordinary crucifixion was like uh well to reiterate there is no standard procedure but having said that um discounting the gospel accounts the evidence is that before the crucifix before you were crucified you were very likely to be whipped and the whip okay the whip would be probably one with so it'd be like kind of cat o' nine tails with chunks of metal on the tip so it would it would it would scourge you yeah it would gouge out chunks of your flesh so it would be unspeakably painful so that then and then you would you would be paraded through the streets you would have to carry absolutely you would carry your maybe not the the bulk of the cross but what was called the
呃，重申一下，没有标准程序。话虽如此，抛开福音书的记载不谈，证据表明在你被钉十字架之前，你极有可能被鞭笞。而鞭子——好吧，鞭子可能是一种带有多条尾巴的鞭子，就像九尾鞭一样，尖端带有金属块，所以它会——它会狠狠地拷打你，是的，它会挖出你的一大块肉，所以这将是难以言表地痛苦。然后，随后你会被游街示众，你必须背着——绝对的，你可能会背着——也许不是整个十字架，而是被称为
um the cross beam and you would carry what was called a titulus which was the um the description of your crime around your neck so that people could read why it was that you were being crucified tom it's very christian of you to be it's interesting how you imagine yourself to be the uh the crucified i was thinking you would tell it from the crucifier's perspective yes I know I'm portraying 2000 years of Christian weathering there you are yeah I think well I I think it the experience crucifixion is obviously more vivid for the crucified than the for the crucifier I think the crucifier is just another working day day. Well, and it is another working day. So that's another kind of fascinating aspect of it
横木的东西，并且你的脖子上会挂着一个被称为“罪状牌”（titulus）的东西，上面写着你的罪名，好让人们能读懂你为什么被钉死在十字架上。汤姆，你表现得非常基督教化，这很有趣，你怎么会把自己想象成那个——那个被钉十字架的人呢？我本以为你会从行刑者的角度来讲述。是的，我知道，我在这里展现的是两千年的基督教文化熏陶，就是这样。是的，我想——嗯，我认为钉十字架的经历对受害者来说显然比对行刑者更生动。我认为对行刑者来说，这只是又一个工作日。
is that we have an account of... They're kind of like an agency. They're like a kind of torture agency that if you're a city council or something and you've got to do your crucifixion... Oh, God, they outsource it. They outsource it. And there's a kind of advert from, you know,
好吧，这确实是又一个工作日。所以这也是另一个迷人之处，那就是我们有一份关于……他们有点像一家机构。他们就像是一个酷刑服务机构，如果你是一个市议会什么的，你必须执行钉十字架……天哪，他们把这外包出去了。他们把它外包了。并且有一种类似广告的东西，你知道，
saying all your crucifixion needs we will you know we'll talk we'll do the torturing you know we'll burn them if you want we'll gouge out the eyes if you like that's fine selection selection packages exactly exactly um so uh so we have that and so that's how we know that there is a kind, as you say, there are kind of various packages that you can have. So you could have them whipped. You can have them maybe blinded.
上面说：“您所有的钉十字架需求，我们都会——我们会谈妥，我们会进行酷刑，如果您想要的话，我们会把他们烧死，如果您愿意的话，我们会把眼睛挖出来，这都没问题。”精选套餐，完全如此。呃，所以——我们有这些，所以这就是为什么我们知道有一种，正如你所说，你可以选择各种各样的套餐。所以你可以让他们挨鞭子。你可以让他们可能被弄瞎。
You can have them maimed beforehand. These are all options. Now, if you don't blind, if you don't blind the victim before he goes up on the cross, then the likelihood is that fairly soon birds will come and peck out the eyes. Oh, come on.
你可以事先让他们残疾。这些都是选项。现在，如果你不弄瞎——如果你不在受害者上十字架之前弄瞎他，那么很有可能很快就会有鸟飞来啄出他的眼珠。哦，得了吧。
Because there's nothing you can do to stop them and probably your genitals as well. They'll cluster around your genitals and your eyes and attack them. And we actually have documentary evidence for this from the Talmud, which in a commentary on the book of genesis and and this is um uh the the account of uh that fans of um joseph and the technicolor dream cape will remember i think it's is it the butler no it's the baker it's the baker ends up crucified he dreams that he's on a tree he's hanging from a tree and this is interpreted as presaging his crucifixion and in this the commentary on it um in in the talmud it says that birds will eat the flesh from your head which is presumably the eyes because that's the
因为你没有任何办法阻止它们，可能还有你的生殖器也是如此。它们会成群结队地围着你的生殖器和眼睛并攻击它们。我们实际上在《塔木德》中拥有这方面的文献证据，其中在一篇关于《创世记》的注释中——这也是呃——音乐剧《约瑟夫与神奇彩衣》（Joseph and the Amazing Technicolor Dreamcoat）的粉丝们会记得的记载，我想，那是——是酒政吗？不，是面包师。面包师最后被钉死在十字架上了，他梦见自己在树上，他从树上悬挂着，这被解释为预示着他将被钉死在十字架上。在这个注释中，《塔木德》里说，鸟类会吃掉你头上的肉，这大概就是指眼睛，因为那是
kind of the softest material so i mean it's a horrible horrible detail and josephus also describes how birds flock around. Just before you get on with your torture porn, Tom, you said he, for the person being put on the cross. Are they always men? I think almost invariably. So the slaves in the house that I mentioned in the reign of Nero, the women would have been executed as well.
最柔软的材料。所以我的意思是，这是一个可怕得令人发指的细节，约瑟夫斯也描述了鸟类如何成群结队地……就在你继续你的酷刑色情片之前，汤姆，你刚才说“他”，指的是被放上十字架的人。他们总是男性吗？我想几乎无一例外。所以我提到的尼禄统治时期屋里的那些奴隶，女奴们其实也被处决了。
But it does seem to have been a distinctively um right suffered by men you so you you you how long are you up on the cross um that entirely depends you know you could be there for days uh and in a way so I'm not a I'm not a doctor so I I'm not entirely sure of the mechanics of it, but it is said that part of the torture is that you constantly have to lift yourself up because otherwise you're in a constant kind of seesawing motion. You know, you've got the birds pecking at your eyes. Your body is kind of gouged out with this awful whip. People are gawping at you. Your genitals are on display and you're heaving yourself up and down. So, I mean, it's a repellent, horrible, horrible fate.
但这确实似乎是一个独特的、男性遭受的权利。你——你——你在十字架上待多久？这完全取决于情况，你知道的，你可能会在那里待上好几天。在某种程度上——我不是医生，所以我并不完全确定其中的生理机制，但据说酷刑的一部分原因在于你必须不断地把自己撑起来，否则你就会处于一种不断的上下跷跷板的运动中。你知道的，有鸟在啄你的眼睛，你的身体被那把可怕的鞭子挖得血肉模糊，人们在对你行注目礼，你的生殖器暴露在外，而你却在上下喘息着撑起自己。所以，我的意思是，这是一个令人反感、极其可怕、极其恐怖的结局。
And so that's why often people will break the leg as an act of mercy, because then you will suffocate and die and your agony will be over. And then when your agony is over, you'll be taken down from the cross. And the likelihood is that you will not be buried in a tomb. So the the guy who was found in outside Jerusalem was unusual. Jesus is unusual in this sense. The likelihood is that you will be carted away and chucked into a common tomb. And that is part of the punishment. So in Italy, if you have the deluxe torture package, you will have people who are dressed up in red, carrying bells, who will drag the bodies to the carrying tip, ringing bells as they go.
正因如此，人们通常会把腿打断作为一种仁慈的行为，因为那样你就会窒息而死，你的痛苦就会结束。然后当你的痛苦结束时，你就会从十字架上被取下来。而很有可能你不会被埋葬在坟墓里。所以那个在耶路撒冷城外被发现的人是个例外。耶稣在这种意义上也是个例外。很有可能你会被用大车拉走，然后扔进一个公共乱葬岗。这也是惩罚的一部分。所以在意大利，如果你享受豪华酷刑套餐，你就会看到一些身穿红衣、带着铃铛的人，他们会把尸体拖到垃圾场，一路上摇着铃铛。
And does anybody survive? Well, that's a good question so josephus again who is um by this point he although he's a jew he's um kind of a pal with titus who is the roman general who is commanding um the the war against the jews he asks titus for a favor if some of his friends can be taken down from the crosses and titus says fine and they get taken down and they they still die and they've only they haven't been up for very long so from the evidence of that the likelihood is is that you know even even a few hours are going to be so excruciating and agonizing that you're going to die of it. Yeah. So just to reiterate, this is the most horrible of deaths
有人能生还吗？嗯，这是个好问题。所以约瑟夫斯再次登场，他到这个时候，虽然他是个犹太人，但他和提图斯（指挥针对犹太人的战争的罗马将军）关系挺好，他请求提图斯帮个忙，看能不能把他的朋友们从十字架上取下来。提图斯说行，于是他们被取了下来，但他们还是死了，而且他们挂上去的时间并不长。根据这些证据，很有可能——你知道，哪怕仅仅几个小时也会是如此剧烈和痛苦，以至于你会因此丧命。是的。所以重申一下，这是最恐怖的死法，
and it's the most humiliating of deaths. That's its significance in the Christian story. I think, you know, culturally, it's far more significant than the fact that Jesus rises, that his believers believe he rises from the dead, is the fact that he has first suffered this horrific death. And that's what Malcolm Hatt is unique at that point in the kind of the pantheon of Near Eastern Mediterranean gods.
也是最具羞辱性的死法。这就是它在基督教故事中的意义。我认为，在文化上，它比耶稣复活——他的信徒相信他从死里复活——这一事实要重要得多，真正重要的是他首先经历了这种可怕的死亡。而那就是马尔科姆·哈特（Malcolm Hatt）在近东地中海诸神万神殿中独一无二的地方。
I think not just then, I think now. I mean, I think it is absolutely exceptional and it explains so much that has made Christianity so culturally distinctive. Okay. Well, Tom, we'll take a break to allow the listeners to have a stiff drink which they'll probably need after all that because after all that um that gore and gruesomeness we're going to get stuck into the greatest story ever told um the crucifixion of jesus specifically and then what happened to the practice of crucifixion after that and of course arguably the most resonant symbol in all human history
我认为不仅是当时，现在也是。我的意思是，我认为这是绝对例外的，它解释了那么多使基督教在文化上如此与众不同的原因。好了，汤姆，我们休息一下，好让听众们喝上一杯烈酒压压惊，在经历这一切之后他们可能真的很需要这个，因为在经历了所有那些血腥和毛骨悚然的事情之后，我们要深入探讨有史以来最伟大的故事——耶稣的钉十字架，具体来说是那之后钉十字架这种刑罚的遭遇，以及当然可以说是人类历史上最具共鸣的符号——
the cross so we'll see you for all that after the break i'm marina hyde and i'm richard osmond and together we host the rest is entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our q a we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad-free listening bonus episodes Welcome back to The Rest Is History. In the run-up to Easter, we're talking about crucifixion, and we've talked about the practice of crucifixion and the emphasis on humiliation and the sheer horror of the experience of being crucified.
十字架。所以我们休息过后见。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde），我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman），我们共同主持《娱乐其余》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一丝八卦的固定去处，在我们的问答环节中，我们将拉开娱乐业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚启动了我们的会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听、加更节目……欢迎回到《历史其余》。在复活节前夕，我们一直在讨论钉十字架，我们讨论了钉十字架的实践、对羞辱的强调以及被钉十字架那纯粹恐怖的体验。
And Tom, I started this podcast with a count from the Gospel of, according to St Matthew, almost certainly according to biblical scholars, I think, not written by St Matthew, the crucifixion of Jesus. So there are a lot of elements that are in all four Gospels. It's an extraordinary thing that we have this event from the first century AD, a sort of fly-bitten part of the Roman Empire, four different sources.
汤姆，我在播客开篇时引用了《根据圣马太福音》的记载——根据圣经学者们的看法，几乎可以肯定不是圣马太本人写的——关于耶稣的钉十字架。所以有许多元素是所有四部福音书都有的。这是一个非凡的事情，我们拥有来自公元元年前后——罗马帝国一个有些偏远落后的地方——的这一事件的四种不同来源的记载。
And, of course, there are others. There are other kind of apocryphal gospels and stuff on there. So we have this. How true do you think these accounts are? Or can we not talk about that in any meaningful way, about the veracity or accuracy of these accounts of Jesus' crucifixion? Well, so there is a kind of... There is a movement in biblical criticism called mythicism which implies that the whole jesus never existed the whole thing is just a kind of riff on you know vegetation gods gods live die
当然，还有其他的。还有其他一些伪经福音书之类的东西。所以我们拥有这些。你认为这些记载有多大程度的真实性？或者我们根本无法以任何有意义的方式来讨论这些关于耶稣受难记载的真实性或准确性？好吧，所以有一种——在圣经批判学中有一个流派叫做“神话学派”（mythicism），它暗示耶稣从未真正存在过，整件事只是一种关于……你知道的，植被之神、神明生死的曲解。
come back to life all that kind of stuff jesus is osiris or whatever yes or adonis or that kind of thing i think that that is is mad i think that that is the kind of atheist equivalent of creationism. It's putting the cart of what you want to believe in front of the horse of the evidence. And the evidence, I think, for the fact that Jesus was crucified is pretty strong. And I will cite a scholar, Geza Vermes, who is generally quite skeptical about the Gospels as historical evidence. But he says that the death of Jesus of Nazareth on the cross is an established fact, arguably the only established fact about him. So that's the measure of how skeptical he is. And as he points out, it's attested in the four Gospels, very detailed accounts. It's attested
死而复生之类的，耶稣就是奥西里斯什么的，对吧，或者是阿多尼斯之类的。我觉得这太疯狂了，我觉得这就好比是无神论者版本的神创论。这就好比是把你想相信的东西放在了证据的前面。而我认为，关于耶稣被钉死在十字架上这件事，证据是相当充分的。我要引用一位学者的话，盖扎·维姆士（Geza Vermes），他对作为历史证据的福音书通常是相当怀疑的。但他说，拿撒勒人耶稣死在十字架上是一个既定事实，可以说是关于他唯一的既定事实。所以，这就是他有多怀疑的尺度。正如他所指出的，四部福音书对此都有记载，而且是非常详细的叙述。它得到了
in the Acts of the Apostles. It's attested in the letters of Paul. It's attested outside the New Testament, almost certainly by Josephus, although we won't get into, we'll save that for the historical Jesus episode, whether Josephus does actually write about Jesus. I think he does, but it's a kind of complicated issue. Tacitus mentions it. It's alluded to in the Talmud. So I think it is is very very well attested and i think more importantly than that it's just not the kind of thing that anyone would have had any interest in making up because it's not recommendation for your god is it if you're
《使徒行传》的证实。保罗的书信中也有记载。新约圣经之外也有记载，几乎可以肯定是约瑟夫斯（Josephus），虽然我们不打算深入探讨——我们会把它留给历史上的耶稣那一集去讨论——约瑟夫斯是否真的写过关于耶稣的事。我想他是写过的，但这是一种复杂的情况。塔西佗也提到过。在《塔木德》中也有所暗示。所以我认为这得到了非常非常充分的证实，而且我认为比这更重要的是，这根本不是那种任何人会有兴趣去凭空捏造的事情，因为这并不是为你树立一个神的好推荐，不是吗？如果你要
going to invent a god it's absolutely not uh and i think the evidence for the you know the so we've talked about the gospelsels, the four Gospels. But actually, the really key evidence, if you want to, if we're looking for, you know, what about the crucifixion narratives might be historical, is actually the earliest texts written by a Christian, which are the letters of Paul. Yeah. And when you read Paul's letters, what becomes immediately vivid is that for Paul, the fact that Jesus suffered death on a cross is an enormous embarrassment. And that the embarrassment for Paul is entirely the point that he's obviously kind of wrestled with with the strangeness of it and the weirdness of it. And in a sense, has kind of made it the basis for his entire explanation for who Jesus was and what happened. So I think that that is absolutely fun. You know, if you want biblical criticism, it's the same as with all history.
虚构一个神，这绝对不会是——而且我认为有证据表明，你知道的，我们刚才谈到了福音书，四部福音书。但实际上，如果你想找的话，真正关键的证据是——如果我们正在寻找关于十字架叙事的哪些部分可能是历史的话，实际上是基督徒写的最早的文本，也就是保罗的书信。是的。当你读保罗的书信时，立竿见影的鲜明感受是，对保罗来说，耶稣在十字架上遭受死亡这一事实是一个巨大的尴尬。而对保罗来说，这种尴尬恰恰是重点所在，他显然曾与这种奇怪感和诡异感苦苦挣扎过。从某种意义上说，他把它变成了他关于耶稣是谁以及发生了什么的整套解释的基础。所以我认为这绝对是有趣的。你知道，如果你想要圣经批判学，这和所有的历史研究都是一样的。
You look for the closest source. And in that sense, Paul's letters are are really really important because they're written within a what a couple of decades of the yes yes but also interestingly people you know people say well he doesn't really talk about the passion wouldn't he do you know wouldn't he talk about it well no because he's writing to people whom it's evident already know the story yeah so this is it it's clear that this is quite a, this is a story that people know about, that Christians know about.
你要寻找最近的来源。从这个意义上说，保罗的书信真的非常非常重要，因为它们是在——什么，在（事件发生后）几十年内写成的——对，对，但也有趣的是，人们，你知道，人们会说，嗯，他并没有真正谈论受难记，难道他不会，你知道的，难道他不会谈论它吗？嗯，不，因为他是在写信给那些显然已经知道这个故事的人。是的，所以就是这样，很显然，这是一个人们知道的故事，基督徒知道的故事。
And I suspect that non-Christians know about as well, because clearly there was considerable public interest in Jesus's fate. For someone who claims to be King of the Jews, to be crucified by the Romans outside Jerusalem, you know, in what's a very prominent place in Jewish life, for someone who claims to be king of the Jews to be crucified by the Romans outside Jerusalem, you know, in what's a very prominent place in Jewish life, it would have been noticed. It's not the kind of thing. So, and if you look at Paul's letters and you try and kind of extrapolate from that, what can we work out from Paul's letters about the passion? I think that you can see that he was crucified, that he was condemned by the Romans, that he had nails driven through his body, that he was buried.
我猜非基督徒也知道，因为显然公众对耶稣的命运有着相当大的兴趣。对于一个自称是犹太人之王的人来说，被罗马人在耶路撒冷城外钉死在十字架上——你知道的，在一个犹太人生活中非常显眼的地方——对于一个自称是犹太人之王的人来说，被罗马人在耶路撒冷城外钉死在十字架上——你知道的，在一个犹太人生活中非常显眼的地方——这是会被注意到的。这不是那种……所以，如果你看看保罗的书信，并试图从中推断，关于受难记，我们能从保罗的书信中得出什么结论？我认为你可以看出他被钉死在十字架上，他被罗马人判刑，他的身体被钉入了钉子，他被埋葬了。
And those, I think, kind of sustain the basic historicity of the gospel accounts. Now, the more I've looked at it, the more I've thought about it, the more I've reflected on it, the more I've come to think that in its essentials, the gospel accounts are accurate. And one of the ways to sift that is that you look at the narratives and if there are elements within it that seem to be the fulfillment of biblical prophecy. So in other words, to echo prophecies that have been made in what Christians call the Old Testament, Jews call the Tanakh, doesn't mean that they're necessarily wrong, because obviously you can cast things in biblical terms, absolutely historical things that have happened in biblical terms. It doesn't mean that they're ahistorical, but it perhaps means that they're less likely. So a kind of classic example of that is the account in the Gospels that at noon, the sky goes dark. That's first of all, meteorologically improbable.
我认为这些支撑了福音书叙述的基本历史真实性。现在，我看得越多，想得越多，反思得越多，我就越发认为，在其本质上，福音书的叙述是准确的。甄别这一点的方法之一就是，你审视这些叙事，如果其中有些元素似乎是在应验圣经的预言。换句话说，就是呼应基督徒所称的“旧约”、犹太人所称的“塔纳赫”中所作出的预言，这并不意味着它们一定就是错的，因为很显然，你可以用圣经的术语来阐述事情，用圣经的术语来阐述绝对发生过的事。这并不意味着它们不符合历史，但也许这意味着它们发生的可能性较小。所以其中一个经典的例子就是福音书中关于正午天空变黑的叙述。首先，这在气象学上是不可能的。
Right. And secondly, it seems to echo a verse in the book of Amos. On that day, says the Lord God, I will make the sun go down at noon and darken the earth in broad daylight. And also, Tom, doesn't it seem like the kind of element that you put into, I don't want to sound like a kind of Hollywood filmmaker, but a sort of semi-apocalyptic moment, you make the sky go dark
对。其次，这似乎呼应了《阿摩司书》中的一经文：“主上帝说，到那日，我要使日头在午间落下，使地在白昼黑暗。”而且，汤姆，这不也像是那种你会放进——我不想听起来像个好莱坞电影制作人——但那种半末日时刻的元素吗，你把天空弄黑了
because that's kind of what the audience expects and it's the kind of grand statement of divine significance. Yes, exactly, exactly. And that, of course, is the moment when friend of the show, John Wayne, as the Roman centurion in The Great Story Ever Told, the great story. Are. The great story. Are you going to treat us like truly this man was the son of God. And Cecil B. DeMille, the director, says to him, could you put in a bit more or John into your pronunciation of that?
因为这正是观众所期望的，而且这是一种具有神圣重要性的宏大宣示。是的，没错，没错。当然，这就是节目之友约翰·韦恩（John Wayne）登场的时刻，他在《万世巨星》（The Great Story Ever Told）中饰演罗马百夫长——伟大的故事。是。伟大的故事。你打算把我们当作——“这真是神的儿子”。塞西尔·B·德米尔（Cecil B. DeMille）导演对他说：“你在发音时能多带点儿约翰（感情）吗？”
And so he says, or truly this man was the son of God. Great story. Anyway. I didn't think we'd be getting John Wayne in this podcast, but it's always a pleasure. Always a pleasure. So on that basis, one way perhaps of sifting the stories is to look at stuff that doesn't have you know biblical foreshadowing uh of which i think that there are
于是他说，“或者，这真是神的儿子。”伟大的故事。不管怎样。我没想到我们会在这个播客里请到约翰·韦恩，但这总是一件赏心悦目事。总是赏心悦目。所以在此基础上，筛选故事的一种方法或许是寻找那些没有圣经预兆的东西——我认为其中有
certain obvious aspects so one we've already mentioned which is the the torture uh and the mockery before the crucifixion that absolutely seems to go with the grain of roman practice and it should be added that when I say that the Roman soldiers are doing it, these aren't actually probably Romans. They're probably not legionaries. They're probably recruited from Samaria, meaning that these soldiers are Samaritans. And people will know from the parable of the Good Samaritan, the whole point of that story is that Jews and Samaritans kind of hate each other. And so that's a kind of a shading to the story that often isn't drawn out. Tom, can I just interject before you get back into the list
某些显而易见的方面。所以我们已经提到过一个，那就是受刑前的酷刑和嘲弄，这绝对符合罗马人的行事风格。而且应该补充的是，当我说罗马士兵在做这件事时，他们实际上可能并不是罗马人。他们可能不是罗马军团士兵。他们可能是从撒玛利亚招募的，这意味着这些士兵是撒玛利亚人。大家从好撒玛利亚人的比喻中会知道，那个故事的全部重点在于犹太人和撒玛利亚人有点互相仇恨。所以这给故事增添了一种往往没有被突显出来的色彩。汤姆，在我打断你重新回到
of elements? For those people who don't know, what has Jesus been crucified for? Okay, so this is another thing that I think is probably true. So that, the titulus, and that has the thing that Jesus is the King of the jews written in three languages so hebrew and uh greek and latin um that seat again corresponds with what we know about roman crucifixion practice and the likelihood is that that is what why he was being crucified he's been crucified yes he's he the romans think that he's a royal pretender and that's exactly the kind of thing that romans crucify people for because he's a royal pretender. And that's exactly the kind of thing that Romans crucify people for. Because to be a royal pretender, of course, is to dispute the authority of Caesar. But then one other question on this, Tom, on the motive for the Romans crucifying him.
元素列表之前，能问一下吗？对于那些不知道的人来说，耶稣是因为什么被钉死在十字架上的？好的，所以这也是我认为可能是真的事情。所以，那个罪状牌（titulus），上面用三种语言写着耶稣是犹太人之王，即希伯来语、希腊语和拉丁语——那个座位（罪状牌）再次与我们所知的罗马钉十字架的做法相吻合，而且很有可能这就是他被处以十字架刑罚的原因。他被钉死在十字架上，是的，他——罗马人认为他是一个王位觊觎者，这正是罗马人处死人们的那种原因，因为他是一个王位觊觎者。这正是罗马人处死人们的那种原因。因为成为一个王位觊觎者，当然就是对凯撒的权威提出异议。但关于这一点，还有一个问题，汤姆，关于罗马人将他钉死在十字架上的动机。
A lot of people who are familiar with the story will know that Pontius Pilate famously doesn't really want to do it. Washes his hands. And then washes his hands of it and says, hence the phrase, and says, OK, fine, you want him dead, get on with it. It's nothing to do with me. I mean, to then say, to have that attitude and then to prescribe the ultimate punishment, the most hideous form of suffering. There seems to be a slight disjuncture between those two things so Pontius Pilate doesn't really think Jesus is that bad a man but says okay submit him to the worst torture imaginable that's quite a big leap yeah and people
许多熟悉这个故事的人都会知道，本丢·彼拉多（Pontius Pilate）大名鼎鼎地表现得其实并不想这么做。洗手。然后洗手不干，并说——因此有了这个短语——然后说：“好吧，行吧，你们想要他死，那就去办吧。这与我无关。”我的意思是，既然抱有这种态度，却又下令执行终极惩罚、最可怕的痛苦形式。这两者之间似乎存在着某种微小的脱节，所以本丢·彼拉多其实并不觉得耶稣是个那么坏的人，却说“好吧，把他交由你能想象到的最残酷的折磨去吧”——这跨度相当大，是的，人们
have said I think correctly that this is an attempt to spin it for a Roman audience oh right so in other words the gospels are being written to try and convert romans and if the romans are out and out baddies it won't work so pontius pilate has to be shown to be well yeah yeah because the gospels are probably being written in the wake of the the judean revolt the jewish revolt, maybe a bit before, a bit after, much debated, but around that time. And so Jews in rebellion against Caesar, it's not a good look. So this is something that has to be kind of spun quite carefully. Although having said that, the evidence of Pilate's term of office is that he does work hand in glove with the the authorities in jerusalem who would as
曾说过——我认为这是正确的——这是在为罗马受众进行美化的一种尝试。哦，换句话说，福音书的撰写是为了试图让罗马人皈依，如果罗马人彻头彻尾都是坏蛋，那就行不通了。所以本丢·彼拉多必须被表现得……嗯，对，对，因为福音书大概是在犹太人起义（Judean revolt）、犹太起义的余波中撰写的，也许稍微早一点，稍微晚一点，这争论很多，但大概是在那个时期。因此，犹太人反抗凯撒，这可不是什么好名声。所以这是一件必须经过相当仔细美化润饰的事情。话虽如此，彼拉多任职期间的证据表明，他的确与耶路撒冷当局进行了密切合作，而耶路撒冷当局其实
effectively other priests so that that idea of a kind of liaison between the priests and pilot is not impossible but the idea of pilot uh who seems to have been very robust in his approach to uh to rebels you know washing his hands and all that kind of stuff uh that that really does seem to be uh i think a kind of slight whitewashing um but again having so so other things i think that are likely to be true because it you know why wouldn't they be um simon of cyrene who you mentioned um helping jesus with the cross that seems to be true not least because in mark, he says that Simon of Cyrene's sons are well known to the Christian community. So he's unlikely to be saying that, you know, if the whole story is just completely made up. Right. So why would they get... Are we to believe that Simon of Cyrene is an adherent of Jesus?
也就是其他祭司。所以祭司和彼拉多之间存在某种勾结的这种想法并非不可能；但彼拉多——他对待叛乱分子似乎态度非常强硬——“洗手”以及诸如此类的说法，这确实看起来——我认为——是一种轻微的粉饰；但话说回来，所以——所以其他一些我认为可能是真的事情，因为（你知道的）为什么它们不会是真的呢——你提到的古利奈人西门（Simon of Cyrene）帮助耶稣背十字架，这似乎是真的，不仅因为在马可福音中，他说古利奈人西门的儿子们在基督徒社群中广为人知。所以，如果整个故事完全是凭空捏造的，他就不太可能会这么说。对吧。那么，他们为什么要弄一个……难道我们要相信古利奈人西门是耶稣的追随者吗？
That seems to be the implication. Right. that seems to be the implication right that seems to be the implication yeah and all the stuff with the robes the scarlet robe the crown of thorns all of that is is part of the humiliation process yeah so that seems entirely possible yeah the fact that he gets crucified at a place called golgotha which as i said you know it's the only reference to it that we have that seems a very specific kind of the execution ground outside the city. Yeah, the place of the skull, supposedly. Women at the feet of the cross, perhaps. I mean, again, it's the kind of detail that, you know, why would someone make it up? That would be plausibly a bit like the sort of getting the front seats
这似乎是暗示。对吧。这似乎是暗示。对吧，这似乎是暗示。是的。所有关于长袍、猩红长袍、荆棘冠冕的事情，所有这些都是羞辱过程的一部分，是的，所以这完全是有可能的，是的。他被钉死在一个叫各各他（Golgotha）的地方这一事实——正如我所说，这是我们拥有的唯一关于它的参考——这似乎是一种非常具体的、城外的行刑地。是的，据说就是髑髅地。妇女们站在十字架脚下，也许吧。我的意思是，这也是那种细节，你知道的，为什么会有人凭空捏造呢？这看起来很 plausibly（合理地）有点像是去泰本（Tyburn）看绞刑时占到前排座位，
at a hanging at Tyburn or the trickateurs at the guillotine. Well, no, because they're not there to enjoy it. You know, this is Mary and Mary Magdalene and they're mourning it. But it's plausible, isn't it, that there must have been people there who were there to enjoy it? Absolutely. I mean, that's the whole point of it.
或者去看吉洛廷（断头台）行刑时的那些狂热分子。嗯，不对，因为她们不是去享乐的。你知道，这是马利亚和抹大拉的马利亚，她们在悲痛。但这是合理的，不是吗，当时肯定有一些人去那里是为了看热闹？绝对的。我的意思是，这正是关键所在。
You would imagine that public executions drew crowds. Yes, absolutely. And that there would be real kind of, and not quite, groupies is not the right word, but there were real enthusiasts of public suffering. Crucifixion fans well and the gospel the gospel says much you know they they say that people stand there and and jeer and mock him and say well you know if you're the son of god come down from the cross yes that mockery is is a part of the narrative um i think the uh the story of joseph arimathea again you know where where does this
你可以想象，公开行刑吸引了大量人群。是的，绝对的。而且会有那种真实的——也不是说“狂热追星族”这个词不对，但确实存在对公开受难的狂热爱好者。十字架粉丝？嗯，而且福音书上说了很多，你知道，他们说人们站在那里，嘲笑他，嘲弄他，说，“好吧，如果你是神的儿子，就从十字架上下来吧。”是的，这种嘲弄是叙述的一部分，嗯，我认为——亚利马太的joseph（约瑟）的故事，再次证明了，你知道，这从何而来
come from if not from... So he's the guy who takes him down. Yeah, so it's his tomb that Jesus' body is laid in. Yeah, and he's another adherent, presumably. Yes. The key aspect of this that does seem to be authentic is... And aside from the brute fact of the crucifixion, the fact that he was crucified on the order of the Romans, I think this is the third kind of key factor which massively influences the subsequent way that it's understood. He seems to have gone willingly to death. He does not fight against it. He seems to have surrendered to his fate in a way that impressed his followers
如果不是从……所以他是那个把他放下来的人。是的，所以耶稣的遗体被安放在他的墓里。是的，而且他大概是另一个追随者。是的。这其中似乎真实存在的关键方面是——除了十字架这一残酷的事实之外，即他是根据罗马人的命令被钉死在十字架上的——我认为这是第三个关键因素，它极大地影响了随后的理解方式。他似乎是自愿走向死亡的。他没有进行反抗。他似乎以一种让他的追随者印象深刻的方式向自己的命运屈服了，
and demanded to be understood and explained. And it's that kind of passive acceptance, the fact that he goes to his death like a lamb going to the sacrifice, that again, massively, massively influences the subsequent evolution of Christian history and theology. Yeah, of course but you think that adds to the veracity because you think if you made up the story you'd have them fighting back or something i don't think it adds to the veracity but i think it's likely to be a true detail because every uh paul mentions it uh the gospels mention it it seems to have been fundamental to how christians understood jesus and his fate right
并要求被理解和解释。正是这种消极的接受，他像一只走向宰杀的羔羊一样走向死亡这一事实，再次极大地、极大地影响了基督教历史和神学的后续演变。是的，当然，但你认为这增加了真实性，因为你觉得如果你编造这个故事，你会让他们反击或者别的什么？我不认为这增加了真实性，但我认为这可能是一个真实的细节，因为——保罗提到了它，福音书提到了它，这似乎是基督徒如何理解耶稣及其命运的基础，
from the very beginning and then tom okay so i i mean i i completely um accept your argument that it really happened uh i don't know i'm not enormously well informed about this but um it seems implausible to me that you've got four different accounts that have completely invented i mean there's no there's actually no real example i can think of no um in in history from this period of sources being completely wildly advanced i mean i know we've had tolling snakes previously in the podcast but yeah that was one detail in an otherwise true story yeah and i think i think that um because this is in the bible and because for some people it's holy writ, infallible, and for other people it's evidence of kind of mumbo jumbo and superstition and therefore has to be disproved. These are passages that are far more contested than any other parallel pieces of writing from ancient history.
从一开始就是这样。然后，汤姆，好吧，所以——我的意思是，我完全——接受你的论证，即它确实发生了；我不知道，我对这方面不是很了解，但是……四个不同的叙事完全是虚构出来的，这在我看来是不太可能的。我的意思是，实际上我想不出任何真实的例子，在这一时期的历史中，来源会被完全、疯狂地虚构出来——我的意思是，我知道我们在播客中之前谈到过说话的蛇，但那是真实故事中的一个细节，对吧？是的，而且我认为——因为这是在圣经里，而且因为对某些人来说这是神圣的经文、永无谬误的，而对另一些人来说这是胡言乱语和迷信的证据，因此必须被驳倒。这些段落比古代历史中任何其他平行的文字记载都更具争议。
But essentially, there's no difference yeah as you as you as you know you can read you know you can read a passage that describes someone you know existed you know a god appearing to him you know we did the rubicon caesar standing on the banks of the rubicon we know that this is attested by people who saw it and yet you get in the accounts, you know, accounts of kind of mysterious figures playing the pipes and all that kind of stuff. So it's no different with this. The fact that there are supernatural elements within it doesn't discount the fact that other elements of the accounts maybe, you know, are likely to be true. Agreed. Because of course, if we were to cast out all sources with supernatural elements, there'd be nothing left from, you know, before the 17th century or something. Absolutely.
但本质上，没有什么区别。是的，正如你所知，你可以读到一段描述某个你所知确实存在的人的文字——一个神向他显现（你知道，我们讲过卢比孔河，凯撒站在卢比孔河畔），我们知道这是由目击者证实的——然而你在叙述中也会看到关于神秘人物吹笛子之类的事情的记载。所以这个也没有什么不同。其中存在超自然元素，并不妨碍叙述的其他元素可能——你知道的——有可能是真的。同意。因为当然，如果我们把所有包含超自然元素的来源都抛弃掉，那么从十七世纪或更早之前起，就不会留下任何东西了。绝对的。
And also in the context of antiquity, to have sources that reference this event within 20 years of it happening, so Paul's letters, and detailed narrative accounts, so the Gospels, that's, let's say, 40 to 60 years after the events, you know, by the standards of ancient history,
而且在古代的背景下，拥有在事件发生后20年内提及这一事件的来源（即保罗的书信），以及详细的叙事记载（即福音书——大概在事件发生后40到60年），你知道的，按古代历史的标准来看，
these are really good. You know, we talked about this in the context of alexander the great or muhammad you know these if you cut you know i came to these i came to the the gospel accounts from studying the sources for the life of muhammad and i couldn't believe how close in time they were yeah so tom um let's let's just start to move we we've we don't want to exhaust our listeners' patience completely. So let's move through the subsequent history. At what point would you say does the act of crucifixion become indelibly associated with Jesus? So in other words, in AD 100, when people think about crucifixion in the Roman world, they probably don't think of Jesus.
这些真的很好。你知道，我们在亚历山大大帝或穆罕默德的背景下讨论过这一点，你知道，如果你比较——我接触这些福音书是通过研究穆罕默德生平的资料来源，我简直不敢相信它们在时间上是如此接近。是的。所以，汤姆，让我们——让我们开始继续，我们不想彻底耗尽听众的耐心。所以让我们继续讨论随后的历史。你认为在哪个时间点，钉十字架的行为变得与耶稣密不可分？换句话说，在公元100年，当罗马世界的人们想到钉十字架时，他们可能不会想到耶稣。
No, no. So at what point does that change? Well, so even in the second century, Christian apologists are saying, you know, yeah, this is really embarrassing. They find it awkward. And I think it's very telling that although Christians do write about it, they don't seem to have illustrated it. And the people who do illustrate it are either mocking them. So there's a famous piece of graffiti from Rome, which it shows a donkey, a man with a donkey's head being crucified. And the wording is Alex Aminos worships his God, which is obviously a kind of a mockery of Christians.
不，不。那么，这种改变发生在什么时候呢？嗯，即使在第二世纪，基督教辩护士们也在说，“嗯，是的，这真的很尴尬。”他们觉得这很别扭。而且我认为这非常说明问题：尽管基督徒确实写过关于它的文章，但他们似乎并没有为它绘制插图。而那些为它绘制插图的人要么是在嘲笑他们。所以罗马有一幅著名的涂鸦，上面画着一个驴头人身的人被钉在十字架上。文字是“亚历克斯·阿米诺斯（Alex Aminos）崇拜他的神”，这显然是对基督徒的一种嘲弄。
And magicians start to use it in their spells. They start to illustrate crosses, trying to invoke the christian god um by the fourth century of course the cross absolutely comes to be associated with the figure of jesus not least because god appears constantine because it appears to constant yeah yeah so is that the point at which the cross stopped so with constantine and then i suppose i don't know theodosius the great or something is that the point at which the cross becomes because it starts to connote something very different doesn't it it must there's a point at which the cross becomes a symbol of power and a symbol of the state rather than a symbol of being a loser it's always been a symbol of power and of the state that's what it is for
魔术师们开始在他们的法术中使用它。他们开始画十字架图案，试图召唤基督教的神。当然，到了第四世纪，十字架绝对开始与耶稣的形象联系在一起，这很大程度上是因为神向君士坦丁显现，因为它向君士坦丁显现了，对，对。所以这就是十字架停止——伴随着君士坦丁，然后我想，还有狄奥多西大帝（Theodosius the Great）什么的，这就是十字架成为——因为它开始传达截然不同的内涵，不是吗？一定存在这样一个时刻，十字架变成了一种权力的象征和国家的象征，而不是一个失败者的象征？它一直都是一种权力和国家的象征，对
the romans oh yeah good point the the yeah the the paradox of the cross is that it effectively completely reverses that narrative because it's saying you know jesus has triumphed over those who've killed him the slave has triumphed over the master the torture person has triumphed over the torturers that's the kind of paradox of it and although you're right that of course when you know with this sign conquer that's what constantine sees in his dream and the cross becomes an emblem of power for for the roman empire emperor the fact that it was an emblem of torture that's not something that they can get rid of and they still you know they're still struggling with it right the way through into the fifth century so uh in the
罗马人来说，那就是它的意义。哦，对，好点子。十字架的悖论在于，它有效地完全颠倒了那种叙事，因为它在说：“耶稣已经战胜了杀死他的人，奴隶战胜了主人，受虐者战胜了施虐者。”这就是其中的悖论所在。尽管你是对的，当你知道伴随着“以此标志，征服”——这是君士坦丁在梦中看到的，十字架成为罗马帝国皇帝的权力徽章——但它曾是酷刑徽章这一事实，并不是他们能够抹杀的，他们一直——直到五世纪，他们仍在与此搏斗。所以——在
british museum there's an ivory that shows jesus on the cross and this is the first time that the crucifixion has been portrayed by a christian artist so far as we know wow amazing um and jesus on that cross is shown basically you know he might like a kind of competitor from Love Island. He's buff and honed. Well, essentially, he's an athlete who has won. He's won, you know, in the Olympics. That's what he is. And his face is absolutely serene.
大英博物馆里有一块象牙雕刻，上面展示了十字架上的耶稣，据我们所知，这是基督教艺术家第一次描绘十字架上的受难。哇，太惊人了，嗯，十字架上的耶稣基本上被描绘成——你知道，他可能看起来像《爱情岛》（Love Island）里的那种参赛选手。他肌肉健美，线条分明。嗯，本质上，他是一个赢了的运动员。他在奥运会上赢了。这就是他。而且他的面容绝对安详。
And that's the tradition that then passes into Byzantine art and orthodoxy. The idea that Christ on the cross is serene in victory. He's a victor. But in the West, that tradition becomes different. And by the turn of the millennium, you're starting to get sculptures of Jesus being shown dead on the cross. And then over the course of the Middle Ages, increasingly, he's shown as suffering the degree of torture and agony that he would have done. And that becomes fundamental to the way that Latin Christians understand Jesus and his suffering and the passion. So his suffering becomes kind of fundamental to medieval Christian religious practice.
这就是后来传入拜占庭艺术和正教会的传统。基督在十字架上在胜利中安详的观念。他是一个胜利者。但在西方，这种传统变得不同了。到了千禧年之交，你开始看到雕塑将耶稣描绘成死在十字架上。随后在中世纪的过程中，他越来越被描绘成经受着他本应承受的那种程度的折磨和痛苦。这成了拉丁基督徒理解耶稣及其受难（passion）的核心方式。因此，他的受难在某种程度上成为了中世纪基督教宗教实践的核心。
But in the East, it's the image of Christ triumphant, isn't it? Christ, the sort of image, they don't seem to revel in the idea of Christ, the underdog, to the same degree. I suppose partly, is that not because Christ and Christianity is so closely identified with the autocracy in, let's say, Constantinople and then, I suppose, in Moscow? You know, the idea of there's say constantinople and then i suppose in moscow you know the the idea of there's no separation of church and state so to just you wouldn't show the emperor a suffering i i yes perhaps but i think i think it's more
但在东方，它是基督凯旋的形象，不是吗？基督，那种形象，他们似乎不像西方那样沉溺于基督作为弱者的想法中。我想部分原因难道不是因为基督和基督教与统治集团联系得太紧密了吗，比如说在君士坦丁堡，然后，我想，在莫斯科？你知道，那种——比如说君士坦丁堡，然后我想在莫斯科，你知道，那种——没有政教分离的观念，所以你绝不会向皇帝展示一个受苦受难的——我——是的，也许吧，但我认为——我认为这更多是
theological it's more the the weight that you put on christ's human suffering which in the in latin christendom becomes fundamental to religious practice and to theology so uh saint anselm who becomes archbishop of canterbury um under william the conqueror he he writes about um seeing christ on the cross and feeling this incredible agony and asking, you know, why was I not there? Why did I not feel a sword stabbed through my heart as Christ's side was pierced by the spear? Why did I not feel the nails driven through my hands and feet and this becomes something that expresses itself through artwork through theology through meditation and that you know that that becomes kind of very very important to the specifically Latin and then Western practice of Christianity but I think ironically one of the long-term consequences of that is that ultimately people in the west become
神学层面的。这更多的是你对基督肉体痛苦所赋予的分量，在拉丁基督教世界中，这成为了宗教实践和神学的基础。所以——圣安瑟姆（Saint Anselm），他在征服者威廉手下成为坎特伯雷大 archbishop（大主教），他写到——看到十字架上的基督并感受到这种难以置信的痛苦，并问：“为什么我不在那里？为什么当长矛刺穿基督的肋旁时，我没有感觉到一把剑刺穿我的心？为什么我没有感觉到钉子穿透我的手脚？”这变成了一种通过艺术品、通过神学、通过冥想来表达自身的事物，而你知道，这对于特定拉丁西方基督教实践变得非常非常重要。但我认为，讽刺的是，这带来的长期后果之一，最终是西方的人们变得
desensitized to the horror of it because in a sense the cross is so key to christian practice that people start just to see it as a symbol without reflecting on the full horror of what it represents i think that's absolutely true. The cross is ubiquitous. Because it's ubiquitous, we don't see it as an instrument. We don't see it as a kind of form, like a much worse rack or something. Yeah, I mean, it's horrible. It's a torture instrument, but we don't see it as that anymore.
对这种恐怖麻木了，因为在某种程度上，十字架对基督教实践太核心了，以至于人们开始仅仅把它看作一个象征，而不再去反思它所代表的全部恐怖。我认为这绝对是真的。十字架随处可见。正因为它随处可见，我们不再把它看作一件刑具。我们不把它看作那种形式——比如更残酷的拉肢刑架之类的东西。是的，我的意思是，这太可怕了。它是一件酷刑刑具，但我们不再把它看作那样了。
It's a horrible, horrible thing. And this episode, I mean, it's the subject is a fairly revolting and upsetting one and i think properly to properly understand the impact that um the idea of a crucified savior had in the early centuries of christianity you have to you have to grasp that you have to get that you have to feel it. And ironically, of all the people who've written about Christianity and the figure of Christ over, say, the past 200 years, I think the thinker who most profoundly understood how kind of wrenching and weird the centrality of the cross is to Christianity, was probably the West's most notorious atheist, Friedrich Nietzsche, who saw in the valorization of the victim on the cross, something that he came to see as revolting,
这是一件非常非常可怕的事情。这一集，我的意思是，这个主题是一个相当令人反感和沮丧的话题，我认为要真正理解——一个被钉十字架的救世主的观念在基督教早期几个世纪所产生的影响，你必须——你必须领会这一点，你必须掌握它，你必须去感受它。讽刺的是，在过去大约200年里所有撰写关于基督教和基督形象的作家中，我认为最深刻地理解了十字架的中心地位对基督教来说是多么痛苦和怪异的思想家，可能是西方最声名狼藉的无神论者弗里德里希·尼采（Friedrich Nietzsche）。他在十字架上对受害者的崇拜中，看到了某种他认为令人作呕的东西，
because it served to kind of sap as he saw it and destroy the strength and power that he identified classical civilization as embodying. Yeah, he saw the cross as a symbol of civility and suffering and kind of wallowing in, I mean, what would he say now if he had had his own I can imagine Nietzsche as this sort of incredibly intemperate permanently cancelled podcaster talking about wallowing in victimhood but then that's what the cross does absolutely so it's a slave morality he famously says yeah you know that this the valorization of slaves and victims are you know and he would absolutely you know he would look at 21st the western world in 2022 and absolutely identify it as being completely Christian in its concern.
因为它正如他所看到的，会逐渐削弱并摧毁他认为古典文明所体现的力量与威力。是的，他将十字架视为文明和受苦的象征，某种沉溺其中——我的意思是，如果他有自己的——我简直可以想象尼采就像这种极其不克制、随时准备取消别人资格的播客主播，谈论着沉溺于受害者心态。但话说回来，十字架不就是这么做的吗？绝对的。所以它是一种奴隶道德，他曾名言道。是的，你知道，这种对奴隶和受害者的崇拜是——而且他绝对——你知道，他会审视2022年的21世纪西方世界，并绝对认为它在其关切上完全是基督教式的。
He would make Jordan Peterson look like the most wishy-washy. slaves and see that as a public good that that is to recognize that saying you know assuming that the execution of slaves is somehow inherently fundamentally totally wrong is culturally literate historically literate it hasn't been seen as that for for across vast swathes of the world vast periods of time and that is what Nietzsche kind of focuses on so he he and it's specifically this idea the paradox he calls it the formula god on the cross that hitherto he writes there had never and nowhere been such boldness in inversion nor anything at once so dreadful questioning and questionable as this formula. It promised a transvaluation of all ancient values. And he sees it as ushering in a sick, victim-obsessed world that he was revolted by. But I think that it's precisely the scale of
他会让乔丹·彼得森（Jordan Peterson）看起来像是最软弱无力的。奴隶，并认为那是一种公共利益，即认识到——说，你知道，假设处决奴隶在某种程度上本质上、根本上、完全是错误的，这是具有文化素养和历史素养的。在世界的大片区域、漫长的时间里，它并不被认为是那样的，而这正是尼采所关注的。所以他——而且正是这种特定观念——他称之为公式“十字架上的神”——此前，他写道，从来没有也绝无如此大胆的颠倒，也没有任何东西像这个公式一样既如此可怕、充满质疑又充满可疑之处。它承诺了一次对所有古代价值观的价值重估。他将其视为一个病态的、痴迷于受害者的世界的开端，对此他感到恶心。但我认为，恰恰是尼采对基督教的蔑视程度，吸引了人们对我们在西方至今仍保留着多么浓厚的基督教色彩的关注。我们依然——你知道，十字架是其中的核心，钉十字架的观念。对于那些觉得这个论点很有趣、以前可能没听过、大概也从来没听过我们的播客的听众来说，汤姆，有没有什么你可以推荐的阅读材料，让他们可能会喜欢这个主题？
Nietzsche's contempt for Christianity that draws attention to how Christian we in the West remain to this day. And we remain, you know, the cross is fundamental to that, the idea of the crucifixion. For people who find that argument interesting and have not maybe heard it before, presumably have never listened to one of our podcasts before, Tom, is there any reading material you can recommend that they might enjoy on this subject?
有，有的。这就是我最近出版的书《多米尼恩》（Dominion），它正是关于这个主题的。我让你这么做真是太刻薄了。我本该自己做的。汤姆的书《多米尼恩》全都是关于基督教对人类历史的影响。所以它不是一本基督教书籍，并不是说汤姆是一个试图让你皈依的基督教徒。
There is, there is. It is my own recently published book, Dominion, which is on this very subject. It was mean of me to get you to do that. I should have done it myself. Tom's book, Dominion, is all about Christianity's impact on human history. So it's not a Christian book as in Tom is a Christian
它解释了基督教是如何在我们甚至没有察觉的情况下渗入各种事物的，以及那是一场多么巨大的革命。所以最后一点，汤姆。我的意思是，这绝对是一个迷人的话题。钉十字架是什么时候以及为什么消亡的？是不是——一旦罗马帝国变成基督教国家，就不可能再继续把人钉死在十字架上了，因为这显然会让人联想到耶稣的命运？是的，所以它被皈依基督教的君士坦丁禁止了，你知道，他说，“是的，我们不会——我们不会再那样做了”——但它从来没有——从未完全从中东消失，
who's trying to convert you. It's explaining how Christianity has seeped into all kinds of things without us even noticing it and what a revolution that was. So one last point, Tom. I mean, this is absolutely a fascinating subject. When and why did crucifixion die out? Was it sort of, once the Roman Empire became Christian, was it impossible to keep crucifying people because it was obviously reminiscent of Jesus's fate yeah so it gets banned by Constantine who's converted to Christianity you know he says yeah we're not going we're not going to have that um but it it never it never fades completely from
所以波斯皇帝继续这样做——并且古兰经将其规定为对那些反叛真主及其先知的人的惩罚。因此随着哈里发国的建立，钉十字架作为一种惩罚又回到了哈里发国的土地上，这就是为什么例如伊斯兰国（Islamic State）——在过去十年里，当他们建立他们所谓的“哈里发国”时，他们重新引入了钉十字架作为古兰经规定的惩罚。所以它并没有完全消失。这太可怕了，不是吗？当你想到这是一种故意设计用来造成尽可能多的痛苦并进行羞辱等的惩罚时。我们可能比我们想象的走得没有那么远。我知道我谈过这个，这让我显得非常勇敢。最棒的是，它不仅向你展示了——
the Near East so the Persian emperors continue to do it um and it is mandated in the quran as a punishment for uh those who who are rebels against god and his prophet um and so with the uh the the establishment of the caliphate crucifixion returns as a punishment to um to the lands of the caliphate and that's why the islamic state for instance you know uh the past decade with when they established their inverted commas caliphate um they reintroduced crucifixion as a man as a quranically mandated punishment so it's uh it's not completely gone that's terrifying isn't it um when you think that it's a it's a punishment deliberately designed to cause as much suffering as possible and to humiliate and so on. We have maybe traveled less far than we thought. I know I've talked about this and it makes me out to be incredibly brave. The great thing is it shows you not just,
就像我在你在播客前提及你会提起此事时对你所说的那样，我说这太棒了，因为它不仅让你看起来非常勇敢。它让你看起来非常善良和富有同情心。确实如此，多米尼克。是的，确实如此。我各方面都赢了。这与奇平诺顿（Chipping Norton）的冷嘲热讽和冷酷无情形成了鲜明对比。我知道尼采在九泉之下都会为此气得翻身。
as I said to you when you threatened before the podcast that you would bring this up, I said it's brilliant because it doesn't just make you look very brave. It makes you look very kind and compassionate. It does, Dominic. Yes, it does. I win every way. In stark contrast to the cynicism and callousness in Chipping Norton. I know Nietzsche would spin in his grave this.
我提到这一点只是因为这是一部我制作的纪录片，关于伊斯兰国对基督徒和雅兹迪人（Yazidis）做了什么，雅兹迪人是伊拉克北部的一个宗教少数群体。我当时去那里时以为我根本不需要靠近伊斯兰国。由于一系列复杂的因素巧合，我最后坐上了一辆出租车，和伊斯兰国一起去了前线，去了一个叫做辛贾尔（Sinjar）的小镇，雅兹迪人当时就在那里，那个小镇刚刚被库尔德人收复。因为我在那里拍摄这部纪录片，我别无选择，只能去。所以把我带到那里的并不是我的勇气。事实上，勇敢的做法应该是说：“我太害怕了，我不去了。”
I mention it simply because this was a documentary I made about what Islamic State did to Christians and to Yazidis, who are a religious minority in northern Iraq. And I went out there assuming that I wasn't going to have to go anywhere near the Islamic State. And due to a complicated concurrence of factors, I ended up in a taxi going to the front with the Islamic State to a town called Sinjar where the Yazidis had, that had just been taken back by the Kurds. And because I was out there making this documentary, I had no choice but to go. So it wasn't my courage that took me there. In fact, the brave thing would have been to say, I'm too scared, I'm not going.
我只是有点随波逐流。那是你在制片统筹面前的懦弱。是的，我们都经历过那种情况。所以我们——所以我们最终来到了这个小镇，那里——你知道，有传言说雅兹迪男人在那里被钉死在十字架上，而我们距离伊斯兰国——那些做这件事的人——只有大约一英里远。我感到了那种存在主义的恐惧，因为突然之间，我进入了迫击炮的射程之内，对于那些人来说，十字架并不是像对我那样成为弱者战胜强者的象征，而是相反的象征——是强者折磨并处死弱者的权力的象征。这把我带回了罗马世界，把我带回了罗马世界。把我带回了一个罗马帝国当局行使那种权威感和权力的世界。所以当我制作那部电影时，我正在写《多米尼恩》。我回来后重写了开头的序言，将焦点放在钉十字架上，以及钉十字架对罗马人意味着什么，以及基督教历史所体现的理解上的革命，因为我——你知道，要重申的是，我的确认为它对整个西方文明的进程以及我们至今如何受到它的影响产生了深远、深远的影响。
I just kind of got swept along. It was your cowardice in the face of the production coordinator. Yes, we've all been there so we so so we ended up in this town where it you know there are stories that yazidi men were crucified there and we were a mile or so away from the islamic state the people who'd done this and i felt this kind of existential terror because suddenly i was within kind of mortar range of people for whom the cross did not serve as a symbol of what it served for me of the triumph of the weak over the strong but of the opposite of the right of the strong to torture to death the weak and it took me back to a roman world it took me back to a Roman world. It took me back to a world in which Roman imperial authorities kind of exercise that sense of authority and power. And so I was writing Dominion at the time when I did made that film. I came back and I rewrote the opening to focus on the crucifixion and what crucifixion had meant to the Romans and the revolution in understanding that the history of Christianity embodies because I you know to reiterate I do think it is profoundly profoundly influential
太棒了。好吧，谢谢你，汤姆。你说服了我，我想你也说服了——我很高兴你没有被钉在十字架上。谢谢。这是你对我说过的最甜蜜的话。是的，否则我就会和谁知道呢——谁知道呢——谁知道呢——一块儿做这个播客了？写信告诉我们吧。
on the whole course of western civilization and how we are influenced by it to this day brilliant all right thank you Tom you've persuaded me and I imagine you're persuaded I'm glad you weren't crucified. Thanks. That's the sweetest thing you've ever said. Yeah, otherwise I'd be doing this podcast with, who knows? Who knows? Who knows? Yeah, write in.
不，这绝对太迷人了。而且我认为我们从来没有真正深入探讨过钉十字架所涉及的可怕痛苦。明年我们可以对彩蛋做同样的事情。复活节的另一种恐怖。带着这个重磅炸弹，非常感谢大家的收听。我希望复活节兔子能给你带来你渴望的一切。我们将在复活节后带着更多历史的乐趣与大家见面。再见。
No, that was absolutely fascinating. And I think we never do dwell on the horrible suffering that the crucifixion involved. And next year we can do the same with Easter eggs. The other horror of Easter. So on that bombshell, thank you very much for listening. I hope you get the Easter Bunny brings you all you desire. And we will see you after Easter with some more historical delights. Goodbye.
复活节快乐。再见。复活节快乐。再见。感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听独家节目、提前收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。
Happy Easter. Goodbye. Happy Easter. Goodbye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde.
我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和八卦的地方。在我们的问答环节中，我们揭开娱乐的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、独家节目和提前获取现场门票的权限——
And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes
前往 therestisentertainment.com。那就是本集节目目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可留下评论。
and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com That's There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
并提前购买现场演出门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。